[Music]
from the studio that brought you
Japanese Spider-Man
[Music]
and the franchise that launched a
billion weebs comes a film with as many
plot holes pacing issues and predictable
fights as the anime but you'll forgive
it all because these characters raised
you more than your parents Dragon Ball
super superhero
strap in for a new kind of Dragon Ball
movie that takes inspiration from
toriyama's colorful Originals shintani's
excellent work on the previous film and
some of the worst looking games on
PlayStation 2.
to update the visuals for a new
generation because the only thing
Millennials actually killed is 2D
animation
last time on Dragon Ball the Red Ribbon
Army sought the wish granting Dragon
Balls to rule the world last time on
Dragon Ball Z the Z Fighters assembled
to save Earth by squeezing their butt
cheeks so hard their hair changed color
thank you
last time on Dragon Ball GT we don't
talk about that one but last time on
Dragon Ball super a new group of Heroes
got added to the mix to the point where
you can barely keep track of who's who
wait a second huge main cast of extended
family old villains keep joining the
crew
[Music]
none of the fish makes sense Dragon Ball
is Japanese Fast and Furious they're
even obsessed with butts
next time on dragon bblz that ass
meet magenta he runs Red Ribbon
Pharmaceuticals but it's a front for a
world-conquering army like at the
Sackler family were less evil he'll
recruit Dr hito a child scientist and
the exact midpoint between Gru and
syndrome with the universe's Mightiest
Heroes Goku and Vegeta sidelined by a
missed phone call
it's up to Piccolo to save Earth from
hido's creations with his ultimate
technique hyper child abuse
as he trains a freaking three-year-old
in deadly combat and once again derails
Gohan's normal life to go get beat down
by Androids but hey when the only
competition for best dad is these two
sometimes showing up is all it takes
Piccolo's not The Stepfather he's the
father who stepped up after some
entertaining warm-ups against Tweedledum
and Tweedle dork get ready for the main
event against Cell Max a Kaiju who looks
like the Creature from the Black Lagoon
ate the creatine from the Gold's Gym he
has only one weakness getting hit on the
top of the head really hard
isn't it everyone's weakness to stop him
Piccolo will have to raise the Dragon
Balls power level in order to raise his
power level and revoke Gohan into
raising his power level before provoking
Gohan into raising his power level again
and raising his power level again but
when Dr hito raises his power level and
magenta raises his power love herbal and
Cell Max raises his power level their
new ally must raise his power level and
Piccolo must once again raise his power
level so that Gohan can raise his power
level so hard you guys until everyone
changes color and gets new hair and
explodes in a white hot ball of pent-up
testosterone this whole franchise is a
metaphor for puberty that's why the
theater I saw it and smelled crazy huh
so push up your glasses with your middle
finger like all the very serious anime
guys do
[Music]
and just make up all the rules as you go
along okay
because Dragon Ball super superhero
isn't here to make new friends it's just
a love letter to the fans who stuck with
it since the Toonami days and an epic
scale animated Cosmic Beatdown never
goes out of style
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight
ah man I should get up and go to the gym
huh
Goku's got it
story my hero Academia finally relevant
Musa weenie hugsley son Android twins
sell out Peter Pan you see this bad boy
in a silk shirt you know they mean
business that's my Superman Dr robot
lift
did I just watch a cat God get an
erection with the Jews The Leftovers
Krillin Me Softly do you even lift brawl
and new balls drag race
The Fast and the burliest
yes because it literally happens once a
year for the past 30 years you know who
didn't get enough screen time in this
one Vegeta we tracked every scene he's
in in the anime to find out all of his
battle stats and most importantly how
many times he stands really high up
looking down on people with his arms
crossed it's a lot click the thumbnail
on the right to find out in the latest
episode of by the numbers
next time on Dragon Ball Z the ocean is
so salty because everyone pees in it
I've been subscribed and posting for
years but epic voice guy never reads my
comment and he never will
[Laughter]